let's talk about arguably the most
important ruler in the history of
anglo-saxon england
alfred the great
his name is well deserved for he saved
england from being totally overrun by
the vikings and touched off an
intellectual and religious renaissance
in england that has justly been compared
with the carolingian renaissance on the
continent
in fact we could in many ways call him
the english charlemagne
these achievements are so important that
i will spend two lectures discussing
them
in this lecture i will focus on alfred
as a military leader and in a later
lecture i will focus on alfred as a
scholar in his own right and as a
supporter of other scholars all of whom
were motivated by a deep christian faith
alfred's reputation has varied over time
it has never really been anything but
positive but during the century or so
after his death he was somewhat
overshadowed by several of his
successors whose military achievements
may have seemed on the surface to be
more spectacular
from the 19th century on though alfred's
reputation has grown
historians developed a deep appreciation
for how important it was that alfred
held the line against further viking
gains
as we've seen though wessex had suffered
its share of viking attacks there had
been some victories as well as defeats
the kingdom was under threat but intact
and another bright spot was the
continuing alliance with mercia
in 853 alfred's father ethelwolf helped
mercia suppress a revolt in wales and
afterwolf gave his daughter in marriage
to borgrad the king of mercia
things seemed fine for now
but the transition from afo-wolf to a
successor was messy
one of the trickiest aspects of monarchy
has always been what to do with the king
in waiting while he is waiting to be
king
we have already seen some clashes
between kings and their royal sons in
other anglo-saxon kingdoms and that
dynamic would repeat itself in wessex
now
one way to keep a son and arab busy was
to hive off some part of the kingdom for
him to rule as a sub-king
athawolf himself had served as the
sub-king of kent under his father before
taking the throne
but it turns out that the system of
appointing a sub-king had its flaws
some royal princes when given a
sub-kingdom wanted to take the whole
thing
it all started out fine
when ethelwolf became king in 839 he
appointed his oldest son athelstan as
sub-king of kent and everyone just moved
up one place in line
but aethelstan died at some point after
851 and was succeeded as sub-king of
kent by the second brother ethelbold
in 855 athelwolf decided to go on a
pilgrimage to rome
this was something of a tradition for
anglo-saxon kings especially kings of
wessex dating all the way back to the
7th century though none of them had been
secure enough to risk the long journey
for quite some time
yet ethelwolf trusted his son's loyalty
enough to leave him in charge of wessex
when he departed on a journey that would
keep him out of the kingdom for over a
year the sub-kingdom of kent was put in
the hands of the next brother down the
line athelbert
and if you're wondering about these
names
ethel in old english means noble
so it was a common prefix for names of
those of royal lineage
young alfred the only one of six
siblings not to receive the apple prefix
accompanied his father on the pilgrimage
one remarkable fact about alfred to
start out with is the very improbability
of his ever becoming king
he had four older brothers
the oldest died while their father was
still alive and the other three served
as kings of wessex in succession but all
of them died prematurely
it is easy in a sense to see how it
could have seemed like god's will that
alfred should rule wessex
and one other thing you can say for
alfred
he never gave up even in the face of
seemingly insurmountable challenges
he was just five at the time of the
journey to rome but it must have made a
strong impression on the young prince
when they arrived in rome afolf
distributed royal largesse and helped
fund the creation of a hostel for
english pilgrims in rome
he met with the pope and other
dignitaries and generally cut a
consequential figure
on the way back the wessex party stopped
off to meet charles the bald ruler of
the western part of the carolingian
empire the trip was an enormous
diplomatic success
for ethelwolf left with a new bride
judith the daughter of charles the bald
now this is an interesting change from
the situation we saw under the reign of
offa of mercia when charles's
grandfather charlemagne would not dream
of marrying off one of his daughters to
the son of an anglo-saxon ruler
but charles was facing viking attacks on
his coasts and since effelwolf had had
some successes against the vikings
charles may have thought it would be a
good idea to widen the network of
carolingian alliances
to emphasize the importance of this
marriage judith was crowned queen of
wessex and anointed
this was unusual in the traditions of
both wessex and the frankish empire
it was the first time ever that a woman
had been anointed and for reasons that
are lost to history wessex had the
custom of not calling the wife of the
king by the title of queen
a rude surprise was awaiting the royal
bridegroom when he finally returned home
for unbeknownst to ethelwolf word that a
new queen of wessex had been anointed
and crowned had reached the kingdom's
shores and his caretaker son ethelbald
flipped out
this marriage with its various
ceremonial add-ons was a potential
threat to ethelbald's position as heir
apparent to the kingdom of wessex
because all of a sudden you have a queen
of wessex with the blood of charlemagne
flowing in her veins
she was young enough to produce more
suns for the king
and ethelbald probably feared with some
justification that she would attempt to
displace him from the succession in
favor of any sons she might have
so when afflewolf arrived home ethelbald
refused to give the reigns of power in
wessex back to his father
in the end
father and son agreed to divide the rule
between them with ethel bald retaining
the western part of the domain and
ethelwolf the eastern part
the situation was hardly stable but it
was resolved in 858 when the old king
died
what do we know about the young alfred
returning to this divided kingdom
our picture of alfred is very much
colored by the biography written by the
welsh monk asser in the early 890s when
alfred had been on the throne for two
decades
there has been some debate among
scholars in the past about whether asser
really wrote the biography but nowadays
it is generally accepted that he did
write it and that he had access not just
to alfred himself but to people at court
who told him stories about alfred as a
child and young man
that does not mean of course that
everything in the biography is true
it has clearly been shaped to make the
point that alfred was destined for
greatness from an early age
astr makes a very big deal out of a
journey that alfred made to rome even
before he accompanied his father on
pilgrimage
while alfred was in rome the pope seems
to have performed some sort of ceremony
involving the young alfred that was
interpreted by much later historians as
an anointing
this was probably a case of after the
fact analysis once alfred became king
but still the fact that the pope had
barked the young boy out for special
attention
certainly left a deep impression both on
alfred himself and on his contemporaries
alfred was still a young child when he
returned to wessex with his father from
his second trip to rome and thus he
played no part in the machinations
between his father ethelwolf and his
brother ethelbald
and alfred is not mentioned in the
sources during the brief reigns of
athelbald who died in age 60 and the
next brother in line atholbert who died
in 865.
by this point only two of the original
five sons of ethelwolf were still living
the next brother ethelred took the
throne and alfred by now aged 16 became
his indispensable right-hand man
in asser's biography alfred is called
secondarius
which probably designated some kind of
official status as the next in line to
the throne
and wessex certainly benefited from the
harmonious relationship between the
brothers which marked a contrast with
the strife of the last years of his
father's reign
it's a good thing that king athelread
had his little brother alfred to help
him because as we saw in an earlier
lecture the 860s were a perilous time
for all the anglo-saxon kingdoms as the
great heathen army roamed pretty much at
will bringing murcia northumbria and
east anglia to their knees
in 868 alfred fought on behalf of his
brother to support murcia's effort to
repel the army but mercia
capitulated at around the same time
alfred strengthened the mercy and
alliance by marrying ejswith
daughter of the mercy and noblemen athol
red muckle
whose mother belonged to the mercy and
royal family and they eventually had
five children together
but the army then set its sights on
wessex arriving there in late 870.
much of the year 871 was spent in
battles with the vikings some of which
were victories while others were defeats
an important victory came when alfred
and his brother defeated the viking
commanders bogsec and helfden at the
battle of ashdown around january 8th 871
the modern location of this battle is
unknown but it's thought to be in
berkshire
the vikings had the advantage in this
battle because they took the field first
and commanded the high ground this is
almost always the best position to be in
especially when you are deploying a
shield wall
the vikings divided their forces into
two contingents and so the men of wessex
did the same with one force led by the
king and one by alfred
the king decided to stay in his tent
praying before coming out to fight
but alfred led his contingent in a
charge up the hill at one of the viking
forces where the two shield walls
clashed and the men of wessex prevailed
the king then joined in the fray
completing the route and the vikings
fled the field
now we get the account of the battle
from asser's biography and modern
historians think it's possible that
alfred's role has been exaggerated and
that his brother's arrival at the battle
was more decisive than asshore makes it
out to be
in any case though the royal brothers
had worked very well together and alfred
had certainly proved his courage on the
battlefield
charging up a hill at a shield wall of
vikings was no joke
but alfred was soon leading the armies
on his own
because shortly after easter an 871
king athelred died
very improbably alfred the fifth son of
his father was now king
now he did have living nephews the sons
of his recently deceased brother
but in the face of an ongoing viking
threat
a minor on the throne seemed like a bad
idea
and in fact alfred and ethelred had
agreed on this plan before the latter's
death with the understanding that
alfred's nephews would succeed alfred in
place of alfred's own sons
this would cause trouble later on when
alfred repudiated that stipulation
but for now alfred was on the throne of
wessex
and he had all he could do to keep the
throne since the vikings were relentless
shortly after becoming king alfred
suffered a major defeat and had to make
peace with the vikings
under the terms of the agreement which
are not recorded the vikings withdrew
from wessex and occupied london
we can surely infer that they were paid
to go away as per usual
and we get at least a bit of material
support for this theory from the
presence of viking hordes in london that
contain coins from wessex dating to this
period
for the next five years wessex had a bit
of a respite while the vikings were
occupied elsewhere
but in 876 they went on the offensive
again
then in january of 878 came a pivotal
moment in alfred's reign when the
vikings made a surprise attack on the
wessex royal court at chippenham while
christmas festivities were still in
progress
many were killed
while alfred escaped
but he was forced to go into hiding in
the marshes of atholney with only a few
trusted retainers for support
with its leadership now scattered
wessex was on the verge of falling to
the vikings
this is the period when the most famous
legend about alfred is set
and i stress it is a legend it does not
appear in writing until 100 years later
we should take it with a pinch of salt
but the story does capture an essential
truth about alpha's reign
according to the legend alfred was
sheltering in the hut of a local peasant
family and he had concealed his identity
to prevent being betrayed to the enemy
the woman of the house asked him one
presumes with some degree of
forcefulness to keep an eye on the cakes
she was baking while she attended to
other chores but while she was out he
fell to ruminating about his situation
and how best to restore the fortunes of
his people
alas the cakes started burning and just
then the peasant woman returned noticed
the burning cakes and rebuked alfred for
his neglect
instead of responding in anger
don't you realize who you're talking to
he accepted the justice of the rebuke
and apologized
the story thus gives us a humble king
but it also catches him in the act of
planning what the reader knows to have
been
his successful comeback
because alfred certainly did not give up
he rallied whatever forces he could from
the surrounding area
trained his men and led them in a
guerrilla war against the vikings until
he could increase his strength
in early may of 878 he summoned the men
of wessex to the so-called egbert stone
named for his royal grandfather where
the ferd or militia of three shires or
counties assembled
they went up against the vikings and
their commander guthrum at the battle of
eddington somewhere in wiltshire
alfred defeated them and then pursued
them to their camp
he couldn't destroy them so they were
going to be a factor going forward
meaning he had to come to some sort of
arrangement with them
so alfred did what christian rulers
often did in this period when confronted
with pagan enemies
he forced the leader of the vikings to
convert to christianity
so what were the terms of the agreement
between alfred and guthrum
they are preserved in a text of the
treaty written in old english
the most basic part of the agreement was
that guthrum had to leave wessex and
return to his base in east anglia
but one of the most interesting
provisions concerned the basis on which
the two sides were supposed to regulate
disputes between them
you will recall from an earlier lecture
that the foundation of the legal system
among the various anglo-saxon kingdoms
was the where guild the compensation
price that was paid to the relatives of
the victim of a crime and as you may
recall
in wessex the price of a person of
british ethnicity was half that of a man
of wessex
well when alfred made the agreement with
guthrum the terms stipulated that each
side was to pay the same wear guild to
the other
that is they were to be considered to be
on an equal footing
there were also provisions to try to
prevent the slaves of each side from
running away to the other side and to
make sure that transactions were handled
in an aboveboard way
the treaty thus endeavored to set up a
system of peaceful coexistence between
the men of alfred and guthrum
arguably the most important aspect of
the peace between the two leaders was
the fact that guthrum accepted christian
baptism with alfred standing as
godfather
it's hard to know how much alfred really
believed that such a conversion would be
sincere as there's plenty of evidence
that pagans who were forced into these
sorts of battlefield conversions tended
to relapse into their former beliefs
there are other cases in which the
pagans did not seem to have grasped the
meaning of the conversion ceremony or at
least not to have taken it as seriously
as it was intended
on the continent there was a famous
episode in which the same pagans kept
presenting themselves for baptism over
and over because baptism brought with it
the receipt of a white garment
and they thought this was a great way to
score extra clothes
alfred was a very sincere christian of
course
so he may have hoped that god would
change gotham's heart
and in gotham's case the conversion
seems to have stuck at least outwardly
gothrum did settle down to rule the
territory allotted to him under the
agreement with alfred more or less
peacefully thereafter
but we should keep in mind that an
agreement with one viking was not in
agreement with all vikings there would
be more trouble to come
later in alfred's reign
and alfred knew this was a possibility
so he spent much of the decade and a
half following the battle of eddington
preparing wessex to withstand further
viking attacks recognizing that
traditional anglo-saxon military
organization was no match for the viking
threat
alfred comprehensively reorganized the
military capacity of wessex in three
areas
its armies its defensive network and its
navy
first the army
traditionally the ferd had to be called
out when the king needed it which meant
that a message went around to all the
shires with a summons to appear at a
certain location on a certain day
this was a perfectly fair system if you
were heading out on a mission to patrol
the boundary with mercia or some similar
task
or when you were preparing ahead for a
planned attack or defense
but it was too cumbersome and slow to
respond to the kind of surprise attack
that the vikings typically mounted
so alfred reorganized the ferd so that
half of the members were assembled at
any one time as a kind of permanent
mobile field force that was available to
spring into action whenever the vikings
showed up
the other half would be tending their
crops and the two halves would rotate so
that the kingdom always had adequate
defense and adequate provision for
agriculture
next the burrs which were a series of
fortifications throughout the kingdom
that were designed to make it easier to
withstand the highly unpredictable
vikings
the word burr just means fortress
and we see it today in place names
throughout the lands where germanic
languages are spoken
edinburgh
bamberg hamburg pittsburgh etc
many of these cities had their origin
and fortifications although those
beginnings are often obscure now
alfred took some existing sites that had
previously been iron age hill forts or
roman settlements and then
systematically added to them making sure
that each site was about evenly spaced
out from the others so that there would
be a roughly comparable travel time
between them and that all the fortresses
were located in easily defensible spots
taking maximum advantage of the local
terrain
in particular
he cited many of the forts along
navigable rivers
he also worked out in tremendous detail
how each burr should be laid out what
the dimensions of the defensive walls
needed to be and exactly how many
soldiers were needed to defend those
walls
we get a sense of what a hands-on and
detail-oriented ruler alfred really was
and critically he calculated how much
was needed in taxation to fund all of
these burks
indeed alfred's reforms of the taxation
system were necessary foundations for a
new expanded system of forts
we know about his new taxation system
from a remarkable document known as the
burgle heidage
this document specified the payments
needed to support the birth
in order to pay for the burs
alfred levied a tax on each hide of land
that was held by each landowner
a hide was notionally the amount of land
one family needed to support itself
there are earlier documents that show
evidence of financial organization the
tribal heidage for example is a list of
tribute payments owed to offer the great
of mercia that dates from the eighth
century
but the burgle heidage reveals a much
more sophisticated and detailed system
of administration at work that had been
seen previously in the anglo-saxon
kingdoms
the point of these verbs was to create a
system of defense that responded more
flexibly to the reality of viking
attacks which were often sudden raids
that allowed little time for the third
of the entire kingdom to be called out
if there were many smaller garrisons
within easy reach of any particular part
of the kingdom
it would be easier to nip a viking
incursion in the bud
but the burrs were not just for defense
against vikings
they also became the nuclei of
prosperous economic centers
of the more than 30 original alfredian
burrs
eight became quite substantial urban
settlements in the middle ages
the modern city of oxford for example
had its start as an anglo-saxon
they served as convenient locations for
the collection of taxes and they were
the site for royal mints of which there
were several dozen throughout the
kingdom of wessex
we need to keep in mind that economic
activity of any kind was risky in a
setting where raiders of all kinds were
a constant threat
not all raiders were vikings
so a fortified location was particularly
attractive for anyone who wanted to
conduct business that involved the
exchange of valuables whether that was
coins or livestock or any other kind of
movable wealth
probably the least successful of the
three major efforts alfred made to shore
up the defenses of wessex was his
attempt to establish a permanent navy
it's not that wessex had never had ships
before but the efforts had been sporadic
now it obviously took some guts to try
to compete with the vikings on the open
seas
but alfred had guts
in 896 he commissioned the construction
of a fleet of perhaps a dozen ships with
60 ores each
he designed his own prototype of a naval
vessel possibly based on classical
sources that the anglo-saxon chronicle
praised for being larger swifter and
steadier than the viking ships
modern naval historians are not as
complementary
this prototype was too big and unwieldy
to go up against the highly maneuverable
viking longboats in coastal waters
but alfred did score at least one naval
victory in a hard-fought engagement
during which the fighting ranged back
and forth from the shore to the ships
at the very least alfred grasped the
need for a maritime response and in the
19th century when the anglo-saxons were
greatly admired
alfred was regarded as the founder of
the british navy
it's a good thing that alfred carried
out all these preparations because in
892 or 893 a very large group of vikings
landed in kent with their wives and
children clearly intending to stay
for about three years alfred and his son
edward fought a campaign that ranged
across all of the territory that wessex
controlled
but they successfully countered the
viking threat
and by 896 the vikings had moved north
seeking easier targets
the defenses of wessex had held
you